my name is what huge things I have a
professor a researcher and professor of
molecular and cellular biology at
Harvard University in Cambridge and I
want to tell her a remarkable story
about the discovery of a quorum sensing
how it came from our experiments in
which we discovered although what we
called Auto induction is in time it's a
more proper word perhaps but quorum
sensing also dysfunction now I was
completely concerned about it with no
objective no idea that it would ever get
lead to anything importantly Danny it
was just a question of why do cells grow
exponentially and have certain processes
bioluminescence for one that don't turn
on for three hours and then turn on very
very fast it's very good so it was a
basic question and and really this is
what basic research is is seeing
phenomena that's named Georgie you and
see what many people have seen and think
what no one else since thought is is the
idea of discoveries it is also called
the non directed research it means
nobody else directs it doesn't mean you
don't direct it you better correct it
and we directed our efforts at trying to
to understand why these these bacteria
didn't for many hours turn on their
genes it starts really with about ten
years of in my laboratory I saw graphs
like this and which the look the cells
grow exponentially not on the ordinate
that the scale is logarithmic whereas
the bioluminescence for the first three
hours didn't rise at all well I didn't I
was trying to find this out when I got a
phone call
all from a graduate student University
of Chicago
his name was Kenneth Nielsen and he said
I'm doing the genetics by luminescence
in bacteria and I'm having trouble and
getting cells to produce luciferase I
said and I've thought of this experiment
I'm showing that the separation wouldn't
always be there
I urged him to come to you to enroll in
the physiology course at the Marine
Biological Laboratory and we're soul and
we would use his spare time within that
course which is non-existant of course
to our study this phenomenon that I was
so concerned about and this graph
illustrates the phenomenon that Nielson
came to study with me and he concluded
that in fact the first three hours there
was no synthesis of messenger RNA there
was no synthesis was of luciferase
protein and there was no activity of
luciferase there are many alternatives
to that that possibility you had to so
we had to show that that was true and we
concluded that in fact the first three
hours was at the time at which the cells
were producing a substance which was
then and responsible for the synthesis
of messenger RNA for luciferase
so that that substance wasn't effect and
induced on we said well this is an auto
induction it's doing it all myself you
don't have to add anything to get any to
get sounds and we took oh may medium
after cells we remove this cells and we
had a clear medium that had been used
for for growing a batch of cells and we
showed
we could isolate from that medium a
substance that would what our course
sells at low density to emit light
well that was confirmed beautifully my
eborhood and nielsen and later
experiments uber hard and the decade
following our publication of the
original paper was able to work out the
structure of the auto and just what we
called the autoinducer-2 be a homoserine
lactone shown here and to show that in
fact different chain lengths was used by
specific bacteria to to act as
autoinducers and they would not respond
Peter Greenberg became involved in this
and showed that very very importantly
cells good cells could communicate with
other species by different different
chain lengths homoserine lactones like
this so having this molecule that
identified he he went out to synthesize
it and the mating of the element with
Ken Nealson
who was his group was able to do the
definitive experiments to show what we
had shown was spent medium he showed
with pure synthesized autoinducer and
here's the way he did it
it's a funny graph and you have to study
it a little bit but he put it in a team
of staff to cause cells to
we had fiction a certain cell density
and as the cells got jet down to a
certain south density the their
bioluminescence just turned off and then
at that point they they kept these cells
nasty at this mile only kept the
glycerol concentration at this level and
added autoinducer they added no more
glycerol they the cells responded by
immediately synthesizing luciferase you
know where they were very few a number
there's no core on there I can assure
you this summarizes I think the the fact
that that the phenomenon was established
by 1980-81 very clearly that that the
bioluminescent bacteria and cifras was
stimulated by virtue of a substance in
the medium produced by cells themselves
many people made of colleagues did not
did not really agree with this
conclusion they didn't think this could
be or they thought it was some working
year phenomena associated with most
bacteria and that all didn't apply to
bacteriology in general bacteria and
general and by 1990s as outlined in
bonnie bachelors beautiful expose in
this series i hope you will get to read
that this turned out she and others
showed that the genes responsible for
this phenomena were present of all kinds
of bacteria and that they were
especially important in in disease
bacteria while the production of toxic
substances mosquito is regulated by our
induction
well how about how did the been that
they the named Warren sensing a
displaced Auto induction for this
phenomenon it is described of a peaked
Greenberg as occurring at a dinner where
any in several college were discussing
the phenomenon with other non scientists
and then one of the nine scientists who
happened to be a lawyer of course said
AHA that's phenomenas really but a
quorum sensing only when they're back
here you get to a certain level and
don't you good enough autoinducer
produced to cause the phenomenon we'll
just call it corn sadly and he
introduced the term we were dead in that
from then on it is history it is turned
out to be extraordinarily important and
many different disease states biofilms
utilize auto induction ataxic cells
toxic species the toxin is regulated by
auto induction by quorum sensing only
when a quorum of selves that is a lot of
cells have infected the body of the
organism are you let's say do the cells
produced the toxin and cause damage and
they really cause damage at this point
and if they produced a small amount of
the smaller amounts of the toxin with
time they would in fact defeat the
purpose because the organism would if
you will in some sense or in some way
since the presence of these bacteria and
raises its defenses against it so this
illustrates that basic research can lead
to phenomenon does lead to phenomena
this is only one of many examples
that well the reader leader results that
will have very very important
applications such as Auto induction does
thank you very much
you